The most money ever paid for a cow in an auction
was $1.3 million.
Welcome to RIF.
In the US, The Eisenhower interstate system
requires that one mile in every five must
be straight.
These straight sections are usable as airstrips
in times of war or other emergencies.
If you get burnt, crack open an egg, peel
the egg's membrane from the inside of the
shell and place it over the wound.
The wound will heal without scarring.
Neanderthal's brains were bigger than modern
humans, they just lacked the necessary social
skills to thrive.
On average, people swallow 1.5 litres of urine
when swimming in a public pool.
Also the Romans used to make toothpaste from
urine.
The Australian $5 to $100 notes are made of
plastic.
Dueling is legal in Paraguay as long as both
parties are registered blood donors.
If you try to suppress a sneeze, you can rupture
a blood vessel in your head or neck and die.
Wearing headphones for just an hour will increase
the bacteria in your ear by 700 times.
Rats multiply so quickly that in 18 months,
two rats could have over a million descendants.
And finally, there is a town in Norway called
Hell, and it freezes over almost every winter.